what is schizophrenia um from your
research from your general understanding
and what is the full landscape of
suffering
and uh
wisdom that schizophrenia explores
schizophrenia is a state where
there's a break from reality
and so this can show up as we call
them the positive symptoms of
schizophrenia
these include hallucinations
hearing something or seeing something
that's not there usually auditory
hallucinations
paranoia people can have complex
fears delusions which we call fixed
false beliefs people getting extremely
unshakeable but completely implausible
idea about something sometimes it
relates to themselves sometimes to the
world
these we call the positive symptoms
break from reality as we know it
then there are the negative symptoms
that come with it and these are
progressive these are
flattening of of emotion as we call it
so starting to express less and less
positive emotion ending more in a
neutral or flat state thought disorder
inability to
work with complex patterns of planning
or thinking so you can't make plans
you'd have poor working memory you can't
keep track of where you were
in a conversation
in a sequence of actions
so
poor
and impaired
working with the thoughts of oneself and
then these
these positive symptoms of break from
reality okay now why does why does this
why do these come together
what's the neurobiology of it again we
don't know schizophrenia extremely
genetically determined if you look at
the numbers could be upwards of 80
percent genetically determined
um
one percent of the human population
around the world it's universal okay
it's not confined to any one culture not
even really biased in one you know
uh culture another about one percent
around the world
and
has this progressive quality to it
untreated so it's very interesting
there's a break that happens we call it
first break
when
someone experiences their first
disruption of reality they can have a
completely typical life up into that
point so you might have a and i've seen
you know just heartbreaking cases of
like this like this in the
stanford emergency room where a kid
who's come there has been
extremely
you know high functioning in that sense
of academic achievement and athletic and
interpersonal and then comes to college
usually in men it's it's round 18 19
when the first break happens
some terrifying
paranoia hits or some
auditory hallucinations start they're
getting screamed at by a voice in their
head
so devastating
with women
comes on also
often a little later sometimes in the
20s
and it can be progressive if it's not
treated
it just progresses and progresses the
voices become
overwhelming the delusions and paranoia
extend and expand the thought the
negative symptoms particularly become
more and more severe
so one can't even uh maintain thoughts
in any sort of ordered fashion um
and then eventually uh
you know it can be fatal can lead to
suicide it can lead to erratic behavior
that leads to accidents
now
it can be treated there are medications
that help
fortunately they have side effects so
they're not perfect you can have
movement problems and
actually a whole host of different side
effects that come from the medications
but we can help people now with with
schizophrenia very very significantly
but the amazing thing and this is
emblematic of where psychiatry stands
we don't have the deep understanding
just like with depression we don't have
that heart as a pump level of
understanding
that we'd like to have with
schizophrenia despite it being so
biological so genetic in its nature
so is there a way
once
a way to return to the other side of the
first break
so when you have a break with reality
it's a way to kind of
stitch it together yeah so some people
that that works
but we don't really know how so
medications antipsychotic medications we
call them they block a particular
neurotransmitter receptor called the
serotonin 2a receptor
and they modulate dopamine as well and
other neurotransmitters
these can take someone who's actively
hallucinating actively paranoid put them
back in a completely normal state and
some people
stay that way
indefinitely so you can bring people
back from from that back to the other
side have it stitched together
more typically
you'll end up in some intermediate state
where
there's a symptoms are reduced
powerfully but there might be still
something there and you've got a drop
down in functioning that may be
persistent for a while
but
concepts what
physically is going on one idea is that
it's communication
within the brain one part of the brain
is not able to tell other parts of the
brain what it's doing and so the
auditory hallucinations are very
interesting in this regard
they often have this conversational
inner monologue like quality as we're
walking along the street we may have an
inner monologue thoughts about what's
going on
if we see somebody we don't like we
might have a thought out where somebody
would punch that guy something like that
or maybe i should punch that guy but we
these are so far below
where we would ever
you know act or even
think of acting but they're just things
that come up and and people with
schizophrenia
those inner thoughts that inner
monologue is not recognized as
the inner
monologue of the self and so it's it's
perceived as something coming from
the outside
uh or from inside but from a another
entity another
another i thought you meant like another
room yeah inside the same building
another room in the inside there yeah
yeah
and so that that's so it's a it's a it
could be conceptualized as a
communication within the brain problem
notifying what's another part of the
brain what's going on and there's some
evidence uh consistent with that
i don't know if you can help with this
but i sometimes because i've been
talking to quite a few homeless folks
recently just
that's what i do is i
hang out at night
and
talk to interesting people
and some of them and i've known people
in the past who suffer from
schizophrenia and some of them like self
will describe
uh as as a as that as something they
suffer from
and they seem to understand something
deeply about this world
i don't know if it's correlated
or
or maybe it's it's another aspect of
like depression all those things that
i've encountered
in my own life
is maybe just the struggle and the
suffering
has taken you through a life where you
think deeply about life like there's
like self-reflection
that society forces on you
because it's a disorder somehow or some
kind
is it interesting i i guess my only sort
of anecdotal observation is people who
suffer from schizophrenia
seem to be very interesting and
very thoughtful in the non-linear way
about the world
i've noticed that it's not always
positive uh
they're the unusual ways they view the
world it was
but it's always interesting it's uh it
could be conspiratorial thinking too
yeah like but like the the theories they
have about the way the world functions
it's often very well read which is also
interesting because they're almost like
looking for helpful answers from
somewhere absolutely and so there you
know they might be citing some very
interesting literature and then using
that
um
there's a stickiness in their mind to
different models of the world and trying
to make sense of that world and those
models could include conspiracy theories
yeah they're very attuned to complexity
and they come up with unlikely
explanations
uh which is one of the things that makes
them it makes it hard for them to
function in the in the world is how
unlikely their explanations are but but
you're right there's a depth of
consideration of the complexity of the
world
and a concern about it
and a work
an impulse to work to understand it that
is actually quite refreshing um
but you know the first case in the
medical literature
uh there was a
classical schizophrenia
there was a patient named james tilly
matthews who
had this uh
he sketched out for his doctor the
uh experiences he was he was uh sensing
and he drew himself as a
a cowering figure on the ground
controlled
by a loom a weaving device that was
sending threads
long threads projections across space
from the loom to him to his arms and to
his body and controlling him
from afar
and he called this the
heirloom a loom in the air
and
it was such an evocative thing because
you know this was the start of the
industrial revolution or mid and it was
where you know
really industrial strength
you know looms and weaving devices were
really
kind of the
emblematic of the most
complex
powerful technological achievements of
the time and so that was the explanation
available to him to explain how
his body was seemingly moved without his
volition uh
and these days of course people with
schizophrenia will have more
technology appropriate interpretations
they'll
have a you know delusions of satellite
or alien control or or beamed
information very very common to have
this delusion of
a government agency
you know sending electromagnetic or or
radio frequency information to control
their limbs
but it's it's the same thing it's that
whether it's a thread from an industrial
revolution loom
or
you know rf you know radiation it's the
same thing just adapted to the to the
moment explaining trying to explain the
world they live in in their relationship
to the world but unconstrained by sort
of
the thing that's socially acceptable
which is that's right both refreshing
and dangerous yes
you